And Allah subhanana wa tala says in the
Quran in surah chapter number 6 verse
number 160 Allah says that if you do any
good deeds I will multiply it 10 times
into your account and if you do any evil
deed I will only count it as once for
Allah he does not do anything wrong. So
here we realize that if any good deed
you do Allah subhana says in the Quran
he will multiply it minimum 10 times
into your account. If you do any evil
deed, he'll count as one. That means if
everyone was accounted one point for his
good deed and one point for his evil
deed without multiplication of the good
deeds, not a single human being would
have entered Jenna. It is the grace of
Allah subhanana wa ta'ala that he
multiplies your good deeds and gives you
multiple times more reward that you
shall go to Jenna. That does not mean
that deeds aren't important. Deeds are
very important but the grace is no
important. Without the grace of Allah
you cannot enter Jenna. Allah multiplies
but your deeds also should be there. If
your deed is there don't even multiply.
If your deeds are zero and if you
multiply with even million times it will
be useless. So deeds are also important
but without the grace of Allah subhanana
wa ta'ala. No human being can enter
paradise.
So because of his quality attribute of
being merciful, kind, forgiving, loving
and grace,
all these are manifested in the great
Allah subhana wa t'ala.